il n'y a pas un détail dans marié au
premier regard qui vous paraît bizarre
en y regardant de plus près
et oui tous les mariages ont lieu dans
la même mairie avec le même air de la
même petite ville de france grand ce
grand c'est une petite ville du sud de
la france d'un peu plus de 5000
habitants dont le maire yves vidal marie
tous les candidats de l'émission depuis
sa création monsieur joaquín fini et
manuel concentrez-vous à prendre pour
épouse du producteur du show de m6
l'avait rencontré en 2013 pour le
tournage d'une autre émission et l'ont
donc recontacté pour participer à marier
au premier regard le maire de grasse a
accepté en imposant ses conditions pour
respecter la loi française en un que les
banques soient publiés au moins douze
jours avant le mariage en deux que le
maire ne soit pas interrompue par la
production durant la cérémonie
jusque là rien d'insurmontable mais
c'est la troisième condition qui
pourrait poser quelques soucis il faut
impérativement que l'un des deux mariés
réside à grans pour contourner cette
règle la production loue un appartement
dans le village au nom d'un des mariés
bien qu'a priori personne n'y habite
vraiment ce qui serait une violation des
règles imposées par le maire un maire
pas si dur que ça je ne vérifie pas si
il y habite bien ce n'est pas dans mes
prérogatives au camer de france ne
vérifie cela d'ailleurs tant que les
papiers sont remplis en bonne et due
forme c'est tout ce qui m'importe
vous l'avez compris tant que l'émission
fait la promotion de sa ville yves vidal
n'est pas très regardant sur le reste
vous pouvez faire ce que vous voulez
alors selon vous la production berntell
le maire de la ville de grand sault
[Musique]
et ce car vous le savez à la dore de
démission non mais vous savez à quel
point je déteste c'était bon encore une
fois de plus on a la preuve que cette
émission est une vaste supercherie et en
plus tous a cautionné par un élu mais
moi mais les bras m'en tombent
alors pardon mais comment est-ce qu'on
peut laisser faire ça vous rendez compte
que du coup on ment sur excusez moi
perso je vais vous hippique et on peut
se marier n'importe où en france si on a
envie de trouver en fait un domicile
voyez moi je suis marié à marseille
j'habite à marseille mais ma famille va
ma belle famille habitait marseille
derrière nicolas ya personne qui habite
à grande haya pas grand monde
évidemment il a fait un truc il ya un
truc qui m'a choqué parce que ce
monsieur vidal seul parce que je me suis
renseigné un petit peu sur le maire j'ai
un petit con piété sur l'axé un
shampoing primaire et l'on comprend tout
ensuite on comprend ce qu'est cette
émission que pour lui le mariage c'est
quoi un acte civil sauf que le mariage
c'est pas un acte civil c'est un acte
d'amour bordel on se marie calmez-vous
je suis non mais rachel ont peut-être ne
pas voir le mal partout se dire qu'un
pour des raisons administratives ils
sont plutôt bien rodée avec cette mairie
donc ils ont changé on peut aussi se
dire que c'est pas mal c'est que on
identifie le programme rappelez-vous
dans l'astarac
il y avait le château de la dame changé
de chatou la marine ne change pas de
mairie reste exactement la même manière
d'identifier l'agent bombe les photos
que madame ait un regard éclairé et
avisé mais il est très intelligent mon
regard alors non mais en fait c'est un
scandale parce que c'est un problème de
l'administration c'est très grave de
faire ça je suis désolé pour se marier
c'est une galère faut remplir des
papiers eux ils vivent c'est facile tout
va bien tout est simple mais en fait moi
je me pose une question c'est ils ont
donné quoi au maire pour que ça si
simple en fait alors là c'est trop
non mais le maire yves et la
communication je pose une question je ne
fais pas une affirmation vraie question
je pense capable d'avoir un éclairage
sur sa ville ce qui ferait pas bon ça
fait marcher l'hôtellerie se fait pas
avancer maintenant comment qu'est ce qui
vous avait dit que voilà les cd mirare
de l'ehpad alors 37 communes 36 1767 mer
et y en a qu'un qui dit oui je veux dire
c'est bastia le mec les super arrangeant
en plus un gros hypocrites et les
malhonnêtes semaines maintenant il se
réfugie derrière
dans l'interview qu'il a donnée là dans
femme actuelle justement ils prétextent
que il ya un siècle on faisait des
mariages arrangés donc que c'est pas
nouveau mais c'est poilant d'élire sa
vie henri morange et on peut pas les
mêmes allégations d'un motif légal
dans la limite de la légalité et pour
autant ça ça reste un scandale bernard
tu peux pas défendre cette émission fait
des zonages deux cents par action
je vous en supplie je vais vous demander
un service oui je suis plein aussi je
sais que la vie compliquée il mêle libre
et à l'elysée oui hélas la personne sait
pas combien
alors voila voila si vous vous détendez
et on salue on salue monsieur vidal
on salue monsieur vidal et sa soeur
nationale est bonne alors on va en
cédant démission la semaine dernière on
vous a laissé sur un extrait où il y
avait des individus qui devaient se dire
oui c'est donc mélodies et adrien et
selon le montage ont demandé si vraiment
à l'aller les rues c'est qu'un montage
qui n'en finit pas assez a duré 57
minutes et ils ont arrêté ou allez dire
oui ou non
et bien sûr on à la fin la voici
suspense on n'a pas la fin ça a été des
fonds dacquois oui mais maintenant elle
a fait ça mais je m'étais emballé les
foules j'entends des voix oui donc là
alors oui oui mais après ça s'est mal
passé
[Musique]
contre le photographe demande adrien de
me tenir par la taille
ceux ci une très rigide très bloquée et
ma main je la mets où tu peux lui tenir
la main
ce concert
une endroit sur la jours
la scène morange et non
[Musique]
non
meron fait deux-trois caresses dans le
dos voilà advienne que pourra
c'est un bébé
[Musique]
non des petites thérèse l'ajustage je
n'arrive pas à contrôler c'est plus fort
que moi
notamment la vie
m
est mal barré et en plus le apparemment
le le père est pas très content non plus
donc ça me paraît très très mal en
braille et regarder les pressions on
peut retomber si on avait envie non oui
oui certains ne retiennent une forcément
viser aussi bien peu quoi
si vous utilisez un coin on verra
on verra à acheter
wen mais complètement bongo papa
la même famille doit la 6e
et ma fille le rose soir
mais si les paroles
là vous
en tout cas je vais tout faire pour
qu'elle nous sommes bientôt sur moi
[Applaudissements]